what's up guys this is Peter I got back
from India and Pakistan a few months ago
made video series on both countries and
the number one question I've received is
what are the differences in the
similarities between Indian Pakistan so
that's what I'm going to get into here
in this video one caveat I'm a foreigner
I'm not from either country haven't
lived in the other country I was two
weeks in each country so let's start
with the differences police I have no
idea what happened psychologically when
an Indian policeman puts on that tan
police uniform something happens with
the ego some weird complex comes to the
surface because typically the Indian
police aren't the best to deal with now
I had no no issues no problems but
they're not so approachable I'd say now
this isn't everyone I'm sure there's
some great cops in India but the
overreaching theme was police are not
that cool Pakistan totally different
this was this was really interesting
that the the police would would go out
of their way to help the Rangers would
guard the borders for the most part
super friendly super approachable so
completely different vibe with the
police in both countries color India is
so much more of a colorful country so I
think part of that comes from Hinduism
you see a lot of red you see a lot of
oranges you say lot of greens also in
the woman because they're dressed
colorfully Pakistan of course there are
colors but just not as much as India a
lot of green a lot of black women many
more women on the streets in India than
Pakistan and this really changes too
when you get to the KPK up in the
northwest territory of Pakistan city of
Peshawar really very few women on the
streets so it's regionalized but as a
basic rule of thumb many more women on
the streets in India scams scams exist
in both countries that got ripped off in
Pakistan by a taxi driver also a guy at
the hotel borrowed some money
seem too keen on paying me back but that
was it India is a different story India
in the tourist places is a much
different story so I guess it's because
of years of tourism I don't know what it
is but it just seems you have to watch
your money closer in India there are
people there are all sorts of touts
there all sorted served little little
games to get money out of you and not
everyone I was in Jodhpur
some sweet guy gave me some desserts
it's not all Indians but much more
scamming going on in India homeless both
countries have homeless people
I'd say India has many more that you see
out on the streets and also more stray
dogs wealthy both countries minority
that is very wealthy but it's very
different
so in Pakistan it seemed like the
wealthy were you know far removed on the
outskirts of the cities high walls
barbed wire motorcades going by creating
traffic for everyone else as the so
called VIPs went through and I think
Pakistan you know you take a city like
Karachi six years ago is the fifth most
dangerous city in the world so they say
are a lot more danger factors I would
say for the wealthy in Pakistan I don't
know if that's that way now or not but
in India they intermingle more it's not
like they're hanging out in the streets
with the average person but you take
Mukesh Ambani the richest guy in India
his skyscraper home is pretty close to a
Main Street of course it has security
tons of security and a wall and all that
stuff but it's you see that in India
more you see you know not all the wealth
is pushed out it's sort of intermingled
in the city's religion India is 80%
Hindu but they're also 182 million
Muslims in the country plus many other
religions over 10% of the world's Muslim
people live in India there are almost as
many Muslims in India as there are in
Pakistan with a population of 220
million were roughly 95 90 percent of
the people Muslim those were the big
differences that stuck out during my
travel
let's go into the similarities interest
in one another both countries seem to be
very curious about the other and in my
comments for my video series there there
are two types of people that chime in
thanks for the nice video Peter lovely
people I'm Indian love to see a lot of
smiles out there
sadly lads sadly lots of negativity
between the two brotherly nations which
one day will come when we can explore
each other loads of love from India and
peace so you get these types of messages
or you get these types Pakistan hi hi
terrorist country in this video
guaranteed if you when it's when you
finish watching it go down into the
comments and check this out you'll see
exactly what I'm talking it's either on
this far end of the spectrum I love my
brothers I hope one day can't wait to
see them love to Pakistan love to India
or the opposite nothing in the middle
crickets enough said cult-like following
Xin both countries hospitality both
cultures are very cool towards
foreigners it's very easy to meet people
not a prom either country and he is much
more accustomed to tourists so maybe
you're not as much of a novelty there
but in Pakistan depending where you're
at it's people are gonna come out more I
would say and then there's a place
called Peshawar Peshawar is in the
northwest part of Pakistan and that is
hospitality at its highest frequency
there's nothing like it I've never seen
anything like it take two steps someone
brings you in forty two more steps
someone says yeah I don't have some of
my fresh bread two more steps a kid
comes out and says thank you for coming
to our country thank you thank you
thanks for being so cool
so Peshawar has been the Gateway to the
Indian subcontinent lots of caught
conflict has come through the area so I
was told the people are very passionate
they're lovers
if you come in
in a friendly way but there they're
ruthless warriors if you come in in a
not so friendly way so come in the best
you are with love and you will see love
and hospitality like like no other place
on the planet
regionalised both countries are very
much regionalised so in India you have
Kerala in the South you have Dehradun
you know the foothills of the Himalayas
two completely separate world same in
Pakistan Hunza Valley and Karachi people
are totally different cultures totally
different everything's different what's
super interesting is you'll see on the
border region sometimes the cultures
bleed a little bit they bleed together
for example Lahore Emirates are all
Punjab people and the people in Lahore
have in ways more in common with the
people across the border in India than
they do with another city in Pakistan
like like Peshawar I found that to be
really cool so regionalized within each
country but then also regions of each
country that have a lot in common
alcohol drugs I know we're in the
similarities category but let me explain
so in India there are states like Goa
Goa there's plenty of alcohol everywhere
are there nightclubs whatever you want
and then there are dry states like
Kerala or I don't think you can buy it
in markets or on the streets in Pakistan
in the whole country you can't buy it
in markets or on the streets anywhere
but the similarities are it does exist
and there are underground party scenes
and all the big Pakistani cities that's
for sure it exists people are gonna say
it doesn't they don't want it to exist
but the reality is it does exist at what
level I don't know I didn't spend a long
enough time there and more interestingly
was were the opiates so I saw in India
and the villages people was like a mild
form of opium I believe they were
drinking and then hashish on the streets
in Pakistan now these are only two
instances I saw I don't know how
frequent this stuff is architecture so
where I saw the similarities were Punjab
you have Mughal architecture in Lahore
beautiful stunning Mughal architecture
in the heart and that also carries over
to Delhi Taj Mahal beautiful Mughal
architecture there are some common
threads depending where you are in the
in the country's complex you could spend
a lifetime studying the cultural nuances
the history geography the politics there
is so much going on in each place cut
off from one another most Pakistanis
cannot go to India most Indians cannot
go to Pakistan there are some exceptions
some visas for family members or
businessmen but it's not easy most
people will never see the other side
that benefits the politicians that
benefits the media doesn't benefit the
people if the people actually got to
intermingle more they got to hang out a
lot know this already but they'd realize
how much common ground there is and
there's no need to really fear each
other easy for me to say I'm an outsider
I'm not talking about the bloody history
I'm talking about 2020 and the fact that
most people are cool on both sides and
the fact that they can't intermingle
does not help either country in the long
run patriotism pride there's a lot of
pride in both countries very strong
pride on both sides the best
manifestation of this is the Wagah
border crossing it's this crazy dynamic
of machismo balle patriotism as super
interesting I made a video on it
actually but yeah both sides have a
super patriotic element nationalistic
element too and then there's a whole
other demographic that just really does
not care about the political tension or
if they think their country is better
than the other one
India Pakistan some of the gems of
planet Earth
if you have the chance go to both of
them it's really interesting to a
compare and contrast I'm just scratching
the surface with this video I know it if
you want to see more about both
countries then go down below into the
description
I made series I have links for series on
both countries and also if you want to
support this channel please go again
down into the link below description
below and you'll see links there to
support the channel I hope you enjoyed
that hope you get to go if you're from
either one of the countries I just
mentioned in dear Pakistan loved it
thank you so much fantastic experiences
hope to see you in the next video thank
you thank you bye bye you guys are very
welcoming big mountains big herds